When you did that there wasn't a completely insane you're doing.
Yeah,
that's the one.
I'm still working on it by the way,
but I,
I can't do like you do with my knee coming out.
I feel like when I do inspiring the guys,
they,
they see it and they they,
so I have to keep my in my knee tuck.
I think you're just thinking that maybe it's because of karate.
I learned in a different way,
so my,
my brain is wired so much in a certain way.
The problem with karate is that lower knee,
the need down by the other knee versus up by the hip.
When you bring it up by the hip,
there's,
there's much more leverage.
It's tremendous amount of force and the alignment of your lower leg,
the supporting leg and the kicking leg is better to generate force,
whereas the kicking leg is almost independent of the lower leg if you're going
up because they're not moving in the same direction.
One leg is going up,
the other ladies going forward,
so it's like,
Eh,
it's all goofy when the hip is up.
When you turn,
the hip is up.
This is pushing and this is going forward.
It's just so boom,
I,
it is throw the power comes from however.
Do you you,
you come from taekwondo is all the Olympic athletes like champion.
They don't do it like that.
Yeah.
No,
no they don't.
exactly.
Do you do with an a different ways.
Right.
But man,
I never seen anybody hit as hard.
Like I don't care if it's a punch.
Like I never see a strike a strike.
I blow from a human being that hard man.
I remember that.
That bag when you were working in it was I fricking whole lot of loss in the
bag.
It was like a curves and the bag like with your,
your footprint in it.
I'm like,
it's Scotland.
Insane man.
It's a lot of power.
I was with Bravo at Ed.
I remember we were freaking out.
Then you want to going back and forward and I like,
you know,
we,
we work together because of Danaher.
Yeah.
Cause John came up to me and just asking me because I was a commentator,
he said,
I need someone to help George with the fundamentals of a spinning back kick.
He needs like a,
like a technique refresher.
Do you know anybody?
And I said,
this is gonna sound crazy.
I could just gotta to listen to me,
but I have a really good spinning back kick.
So that's how,
that's how you put it out and just smart.
I said he put it to me just asking.
No,
no.
He would talk.
He knew.
He said no,
he knew that.
He told me he's going to ask you is going to ask if you could work with me.
That's funny because he said it to me.
No,
no,
no.
Knew somebody now.
But you want to put it this way because Johnny Johnny's smart guy,
John,
he's very smart guy at at,
at you.
You would have,
if we don't have said he would have kind of,
because he,
I remember he said that to me and I say,
because he's like my son.
So he's in my,
in my,
in my size.
I,
Yay,
right?
I'm like,
Nah.
I was rolling my eyes like,
what the fuck is Joe Rogan?
I didn't know what your background,
you know like I knew,
I know you did something.
I thought he was going to think no,
but he knew that because our word get around.
That word gets around that you have a very strong spinning back kick it.
You saw you somewhere somehow told him or he's seen it or B because he told me.
I remember he told me.
Then I was like,
Yay,
I'll do it when I go train with Freddie Roach and I then I,
then I couldn't believe it.
I called him that same night.
I said,
what the fuck was that?
This should be an elite.
If he ever a fight [inaudible] they should be illegal.
You can kill someone with this van is insane,
man.
What's fucked up is it almost feels like a lie because it was so long ago.
It was a different life.
Like I stopped fighting.
I'm 50 years old.
I stopped fighting when I was 21 so I haven't fought in forever.
So it's just I've,
I keep doing it and training,
but I haven't done it so long.
So when I tell someone that I can do it,
am I,
this is us.
Is that true?
I'd be like saying,
is it true?
How many people did you,
did you ever lie it up?
Someone with that video of me when I was 19 from a taekwondo tournament making a
guy fly through the air.
Yeah,
I you serious tube?
Yeah.
Jamie.
Oh my God.
Is he okay now he's yelled,
I don't know.
Here it is right here.
Are you kidding me man?
Yeah.
That's how fucking scratchy VHS video from 1986 you realize you didn't even cut
him like you know,
we talk about precision like there was like,
like your technique is freaking price.
So powerful.
Like you got him where on the shoulder on the,
no,
I caught him on the body.
It wasn't in the shoulder.
You can see it again.
It's okay.
It's just his arm is underneath his arm
and put them on that guy always because it's very crowded.
The incredibly powerful,
like a guy would do the same thing it him and the same spot.
It would probably be not get put away like that.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
See the impact.
It goes right into his body.
And then I extend and then when I extended he was,
I was Kinda like,
Oh yeah,
can you say no,
no.
And that was,
that was perfect.
And he just sailed through the air.
It's just,
it's a crazy,
it's,
it's got so much power.
It's just a crazy technique.
And I was raised,
um,
in a taekwondo school that came from the old school taekwondo before
tournament's see General Che Che Hong Yee.
He trained,
he was the inventor of talk,
one of the founder of taekwondo and he trained a small handful of,
of,
of elite instructors.
And one of them was Jay Hahn Kim,
who was my instructor.
So my taekwondo background was the old school taekwondo for Olympic.
It was even,
even a consideration.
And so everyone trained for power.
It was a different thing.
Breaking.
Yeah,
it was just,
it was you had to be able to defend yourself in this treat.
My instructor,
his idea was if you couldn't hurt someone with a kick,
like why you and practice it and these taekwondo guys and tournaments there were
tapping each other.
They were just moving really fast trying to score points and he hated that shit.
He hated that shit and he felt like you had to load up more.
There had to be more power into those techniques and it wasn't quite as fast as
like the,
the really quick style Olympic point taekwondo.
Yeah,
but that Olympic points style wouldn't hurt anybody.
You couldn't keep them off of you.
But the thing is hard for me,
like I tried to practice your ways,
but I have a,
I don't know if it's my hips are,
wait,
it's just,
it's just reps.
It's just repetition.
Okay.
We'll go over here after we're done.
It's freaking hard,
man.
This gym here,
I'll,
I'll just give you a refresher.
Yeah.
A lot of it comes from the front leg side kick.
Nobody,
I know you and I go back.
I went back to karate training because I,
I've done more tie but I was conferring from karate background.
We've done it straight,
not straight.
That had more,
I don't,
I haven't done it for a backache for a long time cause they don't really do that
much and more.
They,
when I went back to karate,
my last fight and when I start to,
to Redo it,
I've been taught that again.
Would they need,
yeah,
but I liked your,
I liked the way you do it man.
He hurray.
Yeah.
Then he has to be hired to get the full power into it.
I just don't have that same efficiency with it.
It can be done.
You can learn that efficiency shit a hundred percent it's freaking nuts.
Yeah.
But it comes from learning first,
the right way to do the front leg side kick.
See the front leg side kick.
You develop that tomb that that knee comes up and then boom,
it's all in trust in that hip and pop it it forward.
And then once you develop the speed from doing that,
then you do it with the turn and then it's turned boom.
It's the same thing.
It's that twist of the,
the hip and the extension of the leg,
but then it's also the turn first.
So the turn first,
boom,
and then the extension of the leg,
that's where that power comes from.
It's all in a straight line.
Okay.
And then the three 60 when the right leg is forward and you step forward and
then throw that out was,
that's,
that's like get hit by a train.
That is,
that is that one that I,
there's the strongest Cyrus scene is that shit's crazy.
You're running it.
You're,
you're not even in your prior melanosis 50 shit.
Yeah.
But when I was 19 I could do it like a laser beam so fast,
you know,
like in that video.
I mean,
I was just,
that's all I did though.
I mean,
what from the time I was 15 till the time I was 21 I didn't do shit.
I barely did any homework and then pay attention in school at all.
All I did was fight.
That's all I did was dyed taekwondo.
It's all I did.
I just wanted to be in the Olympics.
I wanted to be a taekwondo champion.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's all I wanted to do it.
But then the problem was I started sparring with kickboxers getting fucked up
and I realized that taekwondo has no hands,
like the hand techniques were useless.
And when I would be in a boxing ring and it would be sparring with someone,
they just get me in a corner and started fucking me up.
And I was like,
oh,
I don't know how to do this.
Like I need to learn how to box.
And so I realized taekwondo in a lot of situations is not effective.
It's not useful.
Yeah.
Like I needed to learn how to box first.
And so then I started training that and then I started getting dry train with
Moitai guys getting leg kicked.
I'm like,
ah fuck.
Cause if we were doing like above the waist kickboxing,
and then I saw Rick Rufus when he fought that a tie fighter,
you know,
there's a really important fight when Rick fought this guy and the guy just
chopped his fucking lays out Ronda.
I'm like,
ah.